- Megan, you can sit right
there. You can sit there.
- Hi.
- I love Megan's dress.
I saw a trail of disco balls sequins.
- Yeah, I'm a disco ball today.
- Have you all met today?
Meet Megan if you haven't met.
- Hi!
- Hi, congratulations.
- Nice to meet you. Thank you so much!
- She's having a boy.
- Well, yeah.
- It is a boy!
- So amazing.
- Thanks. You had a baby. Congrats.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- You did!
- Yeah.
- You and Kaley Cuoco. Yeah. Who I love.
- I'm such a big fan of her.
So how's it going?
- It's amazing.
- [Kelly] Baby girl.
- It's the best thing ever.
She's about 10 days old.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- [Megan] Days?
- [Tom] Yeah. Days.
- [Megan] What are you doing here?
- [Tom] I know.
- It's like I'm promoting.
Oh my God, look at the picture.
- [Tom] I know. I know.
- [Kelly] That's my favorite.
That's my, I saw that picture,
skin on skin is my favorite.
- Oh, it's the best.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It really is.
- So is it true that you've
learned some life skills
from, like, some of your roles?
This is what I love about
actors. They come on here,
and then you get to learn these fun things
because you have to
play them in the movies.
- [Tom] Yeah, well.
- Like what's something you had to do?
- Well, I learned to lasso.
- [Kelly] In Outer Range?
- [Tom] For Outer Range, yeah.
- [Kelly] I love you in Outer Range.
I'm obsessed with Outer
Range, but I can't do that.
I tried to lasso.
- Yeah, well Brolin taught me.
So Brolin was like-
- Shut up. Brolin taught you how to-
- He knows how to lasso.
- [Kelly] Your life is cool. That's cool.
Did you do well like right off the bat?
- Yeah, I did pretty well with
lassoing right off the bat.
The horseback riding, not so much.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- No.
- So you didn't, wait, what do you mean?
- [Megan] Tough one.
- Did you fall off?
- No, I wish I did.
(audience laughs)
I mean, I feel like at a certain point-
- He's over it.
- I think it would've been less painful
and embarrassing had I fallen off.
- No, I've fallen off
of a horse. It hurts.
- [Tom] Where did you grow up?
- Texas.
- Okay. See, I grew up in New Jersey.
- So not a lot of horses happening there.
- No, we're not really
riding a lot of horses.
- You sound like you're from Texas though.
- Do I?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I know you do the accent.
- I was like Jersey?
- [Kelly] I know. It does
not sound Jersey at all. Wow.
- Yeah.
- I love that you- so you
didn't fall off the horse
or did it buck with
you on it or something?
What happened?
- No, it was the trotting.
I was, we were on, well
I'm not a musician,
but I guess downbeat wrong.
Like a bad rhythm.
- Yeah.
- You know, the horse would
go up and I would come down.
- Oh, and that can feel like-
- Oh no no no, you gotta find that gait.
- It was really painful.
It was really painful.
- Yeah. Alright.
Right. Well, tell us about
your new show Love and Death.
- Yeah. Well, it's a true crime story.
It was a murder that took place
in a really small Texas town.
- [Kelly] Of course it's Texas.
- [Megan] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Why is it always us?
- Yeah. It's you.
- What's wrong with us?
- Yeah.
- It's a really small community,
and there was an affair that took place,
and it ultimately resulted
in someone getting killed.
And our show is kind of about
how that crime happened.
And then the trial that followed, I play-
the woman who is accused of
the crime is Candy Montgomery.
And I play Don Crowder, her
lawyer you saw on the clip
who is just kind of a
member of the community.
And up until he tried that crime with her
was a personal injury guy.
- Really?
- He was just like, you
know, "Hey, you know,
you fall on the job, you
call Don Crowder." That kind.
- So wait, when Kaley was
here, we talked about-
she loves true crime.
Do you love true crime?
- Yeah, I do. I do.
Not as much as Kaley, but I do.
- [Kelly] I can't. I can't,
because I get very nervous about
what humans are capable of.
I don't think I want to know.
- Yeah. It is scary.
- [Kelly] Because it scares me.
I'm just like, "what?"
And like, "how did that happen?"
And then they'll be like, "Hey,
they were just a normal
family. And then one day..."
and I'm like, "I don't want to hear that!"
- [Tom] I know.
- [Kelly] I want to know
there were real signs.
(Tom laughs)
Like, I don't want some kid to just-
- I fall asleep listening
to that every night.
- [Kelly] Really?
- Dateline.
- [Tom] Really? Wow.
- [Kelly] What?
- I'm sick! But so does Kris Jenner.
- [Kelly] I tried-
(laughs) That's your bar?
- She does too.
She does it as much.
- I can't. But you like it,
just not as much as her.
- Yeah. I like it on a
good cross-country drive.
I have a dog. I bring
him with me everywhere.
So we drive.
- [Megan] What's your dog's name?
- Blue.
- What?
- Yeah.
- That's a great name.
- [Megan] They're so good.
- Well, we have six now.
- [Kelly] You have six dogs?
- Yeah.
- I did know she liked dogs too.
- But only one, only Blue
makes the road trips?
- Blue's the big German shepherd.
He makes the road trips
because he can't fly.
- Oh, I love German shepherds.
- Yeah.
- Do you not like to fly
or is it only because you-
- I don't mind flying,
but I'd rather drive
and listen to podcasts
and have Blue with me.
- [Kelly] That's cool. I like that too.
And it's alone time. It's nice.
- I know, I know.
- Enjoy it. You're only 10 days in.
- Well, it's done. Those days are done.
As Kaley would say, if she was here.
Those days are done.
- All right.
Let's do another commercial
break, everybody.
Tom's show Love and Death
premieres Thursday on HBO Max.